Hey guys, Pete here. this will be my Game
of Thrones season 8 episode 5 trailer
breakdown. episode 4 brought us to King's
Landing and this trailer really only
shows us the main characters preparing
for the coming battle. there is no voice
over in this trailer just music in a
ticking clock at the very end we get a
hint of Drogon being involved but we
definitely don't see him. this is the
setup for the final battle of the Game
of Thrones series. my initial take away
is that they're focusing on the suspense
leading up to the battle and leaving us
guessing about everything else which
isn't surprising considering the
magnitude of the battle and the fact
that this is the penultimate episode of
a series that has been known for
penultimate episode. the image that stood
out to me the most was Tyrion walking up
to Daenerys in the map room at
Dragonstone it really shows how screwed
she actually is here. in episode 4 we see
her lose everything for the most part
and we see how Tyrion who is supposed to
be her most trusted adviser is still
torn about how things should proceed.
when I saw him I thought he should be
approaching her to tell her that they
need to take care of Cersei by some
other means besides the straight-up
battle get a team together have them
sneak into the red keep to dispatch her
and save the lives of everyone she has
positioned as a giant human shield
around her there are several people on
Daenerys aside that are capable of doing
this and in fact actually just recently
did this then I realized that Tyrion has
made it plain that Cersei and the life
of her unborn child still influences
decision making and that is probably
going to be a problem the second thing
that caught my attention we'll talk
about when we get to it so let's look at
the scene by scene and then talk about
what it tells us about episode 5 the
penultimate episode of the Game of
Thrones series. the trailer opens with a
shot of Dragonstone we see Daenerys from
behind looking at the sea and her hand
Tyrion approaching no one else seems to
be present so it looks like Daenerys was
alone thinking about the coming battle we get a
close-up of Tyrions face as he's walking
he looks serious and cautious he could
be coming to make up lead to Daenerys to
change her strategy or he could be
coming to take her temperature before
things get started he could be coming to
rat out Varys but I think something else
would have to happen to move him in that
direction as things were left at the end
of the last episode it seems that the
people Daenerys trusts who advised her
are all willing to consider other
options at the very least Cersei is
looking out the window again and what
stands out here is the scorpions along
the walls in the last episode we saw
them outside the gates and this picture
makes it look like they basically
stretch all the way around the city they
look like they would be fairly effective
if Daenerys tried to fly up to the city
low to the ground beyond that I'm not
really sure about what their range is or
how high dragons can fly so I can't say
if this is great planning of the
defences by Qyburn or something that
looks way more effective than it might
actually be. the camera comes around to
look at Cersei from the front she looks
to be alone with the mountain guarding
her and appears to be pleased with how
things are going down I don't think
there's much more to say about that but
it does give off some serious season six
finale vibe and the next shot we see
that Jon Snow and Davos have arrived
they positioned the remaining troops
outside of King's Landing and we can see
that there is more than a handful of
troops left the thing that stands out
and this shot is the fact that the
golden company is outside of the walls
I'm not a military strategist but this
looks odd to me but yes Jon has arrived
and is surveying the situation with
Davos and Tyrion the angle changes so we
see Jon from the front and he looks
tense I'm not sure but I think this is
later than the last image and that one
you see him looking over the troops from
a hill and this one it looks like he
took a position out in front of the men
I don't think there would be any troops
behind him on the shot from the hill but
either way he looked serious and
probably should be the golden company
looks fresh and should have the upper
hand here even if it is weird that they
went outside the walls we see your own
ships on the water outside the city it
cuts to a shot of him on
and we see the Scorpion behind him to
remind us that it wouldn't be a good
idea to fly a dragon in this direction
either he looks like he is a little
anxious and is waiting to see where
Daenerys might come from after that we
get a dark look at the throne room in
Dragonstone when I brighten it and zoom
in it looks like Daenerys is sitting on
her throne
there are unsullied off to both sides
and two people are standing in front of
her Tyrion is the one on the left and
it's not clear who is the one on the
right if I had to guess I would say it's
Varys and at least don't see anything to
make me think it isn't him besides that
I don't know he can draw any conclusion
about what's going on we do see Tyrion
from the front in the next shot and he
looks concerned but again not much as
far as why this is an important scene
and why they decided to add it to the
trailer the next shot is the golden
company marching through King's Landing
looks like they're going out of the
gates we see the city behind them on
first glance they look most likely to be
going to take their positions outside of
the walls where we saw them earlier they
look impressive seasoned and ready for
the battle when you look at the image
closer though there's definitely a
hooded captive with them this is the
second thing that stood out to me about
this trailer and my first thought was
that who could Cersei have captured that
she could send out to the battlefield to
turn the tides and get them to surrender
they do appear to be walking out of the
gates not bringing someone inside it
looks like a man for sure and so my
first thought was Jaime we know he's
headed there perhaps he turned himself
in and when he arrived and they ended up
taking him captive rather than taking
him to Cersei or they took him to Cersei
and she didn't accept him it's confusing
though showing that Jaime as a prisoner
would be helpful to Cersei in this
battle how why would Jon Snow or
Daenerys care if he was captured
Tyrion would care but how would his
knowing change anything it's not like
they're going to do a prisoner exchange
like Daenerys is gonna give up her hand
of the king in order to free Jaime like
it just doesn't really make sense so it
could not be Jaime it could be someone
else but I don't know who that other
person is
that would be so important to John and
Daenerys aside I haven't been able to
come up with a good answer for who this
is and as I've been looking around I
haven't seen a good answer as to who
this is either so you guys are gonna
have to tell me what you think in the
comments do you think they're taking
this person out to the battlefield and
what do you actually think is going on
here.
who is it why does it matter? after that
we get a close-up shot of Greyworm who
looks just like you would expect him to
look after losing the Missandei there's
really no question what he wants to do
and how ready he is for this battle
there's another profile shot of Cersei
that reminds us of her blowing up the
Sept of Baelor it hints that she's
equally prepared to get rid of her
enemies here as she was that day since
we don't expect her to come out on top
it leaves me wondering how this will all
go wrong for her there is a shot of the
Lannister soldiers loading a bolt onto
one of the scorpions we get a look at
the Lannister lion head on the front of
the weapon and can see how lethal the
bolt itself actually looks then there is
the silent shot of the sky we see that
there are some clouds and it looks like
a dragon could come breaking through
them at any second then we get the last
shot of the trailer and it's Euron
standing on the deck of the silence he's
looking up using his arm to shield the
Sun we hear the sound of Drogon as it
zooms in on his face we see his
expression change to one of concern and
then it fades to black this feels a
little suspect to me I don't know what
he's looking at I mean he changes his
look he sees something he's worried but
I don't think we should assume that this
is tied into that dragon sound that they
played overtop
either way the trailer ends there and
we'll have to wait until next week to
find out so we know the battle is going
to happen and we see everyone getting
into position we get no images of anyone
who isn't directly related to the fight
for King's Landing
we don't really see any character stuff
going on leading up to that other than
the couple of shots we get of Daenerys
and Tyrion there's no shots of the north
no shots of the characters who should
still be on their way south and only a
character with a hood over his head that
hints that Cersei has more up her sleeve
than we thought as I said in the
beginning things aren't looking
favorable for De Niro
john has arrived we know based on his
character that what he told her about
being his queen will still stand but he
might be the only person on her side
that is actually committed and there's
also his personal conflict involved in
that I imagine they will have a reunion
before he heads out to the battlefield
but we don't get any evidence of that
here of course we have seen in previous
trailers that they're in Dragonstone
together so that will probably happen
before the battle itself the shot in the
throne room sure looks ominous since
it's dark and we don't know what's going
on since it looks like Varys is up in
the front of the room and they only
showed his Tyrions face it might hint at
something going on with him maybe she
finds out about his betrayal but there's
not enough here to say that they're not
just discussing the plan or how they're
gonna move forward after things get
wrapped up it's important to remember
that this is an 80-minute episode and
there's a ton of stuff that they're just
not showing us here the battle and the
taking of King's Landing or the
destruction of King's Landing or
whatever that turns out to be isn't
gonna be the entire episode I don't
think like we saw with the Battle of
Winterfell however I do believe that the
end of the battle will kind of be the
end of the episode so there should be a
lot of build-up even though things were
already in place you know
Cersei definitely got them ready to
attack at the end of the last episode
and I think most of what's gonna happen
here is gonna happen before they
actually do that and I'm really curious
as to how they're gonna fill up this
entire 80-minute for now I'll leave it
there I want to get going on the other
stuff I have to work on for this
previous episode I wanted to get this
video out first let me know in the
comments what you think who is the
hooded character what's going on
material what's going on with Varys what
will Daenerys actually do is there any
real path forward for her to use the
dragons I don't really know like I said
the defense looks really impressive but
is there some way that she can get
around that I just really don't know I
do know that her lack of support is
probably going to turn out to be a
bigger issue altogether and so I'll
leave it there please like the video if
you enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel
to follow along with the rest of the
season we only have two more episodes to
go let me know what you're thinking in
the comments and thanks for watching I
will talk to you soon